alors on va commencer par le premier
s'est il s'appelle le placenta biggs
baby food voilà donc à lampard donc ça
c'était là le premier c'est le régime de
adel la chanteuse s'appelle le régime
séquentielle ou jeunes intermittents
leurs jolis seins c'est le régime à la
mode chez les stars kourtney kardashian
bien deux c'est ben affleck et nicole
kidman delormeau certains adoptent eux
pour mettre leur corps au repos d'autres
pratiques religieuses en fait c'est
quelque part c'est aussi a compris on
mange pendant 16 heures non non non non
c'est la mer je vais manger et on
s'arrête bon successeur le jeune
séquentiel pendant ses soeurs on arrête
deux manches assez ça mais on s'hydrate
et non très bien d'accord temps sans
calorie bien évidemment sans succès aux
édulcorants donc c'est plutôt à faire la
nuit le soir on s'arrête de manger la
nuit ont fait on pas ça dure pas au lieu
de trois d'accord en fait à chaque
seconde on produit 20 millions de
cellules pour remplacer nos cellules
musée ou mortes il laurie star auto
copie augmente avec l'âge pouvant donner
lieu par exemple à des cancers mais
quand on pratique le jeu de séquentiel
on renforce son adn il ya moins d'un an
de copies de dire le teint plus clair
plus tonique mohandas un délai requis -
trimestre qu'il est bon celui là ah oui
en fait comme pour dire été mon coach de
sport le faire en ce moment
digérer c'est pas rien on fait
travailler une dizaine d'organes le foie
alors allez pancréas c'est une usine est
en fait quand on pratique ce jeune le
corps se met au repos on a le temps de
se réparer de régénérer vous avez tous
les cinq jours on refait complètement la
tapisserie des intestins toutes les
cellules il faut le temps qu'elle se
replacent que je peux la résumer je
mange toute la journée docteur le soir
j'arrête de manger la nuit a passé ses
huit heures le lendemain je m'hydrate je
bois mais pendant huit heures encore je
ne mange pas sarah fait passer 16 heures
et après je mange oui mais sauf que si
on veut vraiment maigrir oui pendant les
huit heures pendant lesquelles on a le
droit de manger on est quand même obligé
d'avoir une régulation de son
alimentation oui c'est pas par burki
voilà et ça peut se faire sur le repas
du soir mais ça peut se faire aussi sur
le petit déjeuner ça veut dire que par
exemple vous pouvez choisir de manger le
midi de manger le soir et de laisser
passer 16 heures et d'enlever le petit
déjeuner et pendant ces huit heures vous
allez manger il va falloir quand même
contrôlé un peu votre alliance mais
c'est plutôt un bon régime c'est plutôt
bien on va très bien j'ajouterai que mes
découvertes là-dessus formidable on a
découvert que ça monte l'immunité c'est
un prix nobel japonais quêtes de groupe
hersant les vraies limites étaient
beaucoup plus forte l'inflammation qui
est la porte d'entrée toutes les
maladies
chut on sécrète une petite molécule
qu'il s'appelle bdnf on pense plus
rapide plus vite excellente accusé
cérébrale et on sécrète l'hormone de
croiser deux marins croissance jusqu'à
3000 % qui est l'une dans une vraie
source de jouvence donc en fait tout se
passe comme si dans une vie peut le
faire comme une fois dans sa vie à peu
près ce truc-là chaud là bas le jeune en
fait on le fait tant qu'on veut il faut
quand même être bien dans sa vie et dans
son corps d'accord ça veut dire si on
anglais les actes il n'y a pas de danger
à le faire à les email est très clair
mais question un peu un peu conne mais
jamais dit d'arrêter de manger pendant
16 heures mais si on sa 18h c'est encore
mieux oui c'est ça certains lieux après
que murray
lui décède assez curieusement ça a été
testé ces artistes et un jeune de seize
heures un jeune de vingt heures arènes
d'oran dans le jeune de seize heures on
va entamer une mobilisation des graisses
qui était meilleure c'est pour ça que
c'était assez stupéfiant de bois que 16
heures c'était mieux que maints de
kapalata comme celle ci dont les
léopards bon voilà les gens qui font
ramadan sont son père exemple sans super
exemple il déjà ils sont très courageux
parce que moi j'ai essayé au bout de
trois heures je sais au mcdonald's
chez les filles et énormément d'énergie
j'ai pas mangé problème que le maïdo
était entourée de joyeux avec plein de
soccer jeunes pendant le ramadan mais
c'est incroyable et son ampleur ces gens
ramadan c'est quasiment un jeune
intermittents très lourd puisque on boit
même pas iam et un tiers des gens vont
grossir un tiers vont maigrir un tiers
vont se stabiliser ce qui prouve bien
que pendant les huit heures où on mange
on est quand même obligé bien sûr alors
chers de 10 mois de nantes voudrait pas
que le ramadan est un exemple incroyable
et on n'est pas avéré bbbbb on va pas on
ne peut pas ramadan d'aghrib et oui on
peut pas devenir musulman pour risques
pour maigrir alors là on va rester sur
les régimes gens qui font maintenant
qu'ils sont pas musulmans juste pour le
gène et pour le corps
alors attention lui vient comme il a
beaucoup j'ai donc fait un formidable et
très clair merci merci docteur alors
victoria beckham évidemment elle à la
méthode five
c'est elle avait alors c'est on appelle
aussi régime des cinq paniers de
nourriture en gros c'est très simple le
régime consiste à manger cinq fois dans
la journée une portion de n'importe quoi
mais en point mais qui tient pendant la
nuit ouais c'est d'aimia caouette
alors ça bien pas bien joué et les
autres il ya dix ans d'études ne leur
truc pas bien pourquoi pas bien parce
que toute façon celle inverse ce qu'on
venait de dire un lieu de laisser le
corps au repos en qu'ils m'entendent et
manger tout le temps on mange tout le
temps certes ça ne s'arrête pas c'est
pas bon du tout et une poignée ça
correspond à quoi d'ailleurs
c'est surtout une arnaque parce que
grosso modo le volume des aliments dans
une journée c'est entre 1,75 et 2 kg
quand tu prends une poignée maximum tu
peux mettre 80 100 g donc en fait elle
est en train de nous dire qu'au lieu de
manger un kilo et demi ou deux kilos
d'aliments elle va manger 600 g toujours
michel il s'agissait d'une étude qui a
marché sur le pardon sur les chiens aux
états unis qui montrait que plutôt que
leur donner de temps en temps tu remplis
la gamelle et le ventre animal roclenge
quantique en ce sens il veut la même
erreur de la société c'est la même chose
c'est ça veut dire quand tu sollicite
les gens avec une alimentation monotone
en général ils mangent exclusivement à
leurs fins si tu les sollicitent avec
une alimentation très variés des bonbons
biscuits des petits apéritif la
stimulation alimentaire elle va faire
que les gens mangent plus que ce qu'ils
auraient femme parce qu'ils ont
simplement envie de manger ses
gourmandises alors attention le suivant
le suivant à ce que la sueur ils
essaient de risque il était pas une
menace sur
l'a8 wade magnifique merci et les gens
le disent des missions à mission c'est
vrai c'est vrai ce serait arrivé avec un
petit look un peu à peu racaille pas
paradis ils ont cherché dans la rue et
maintenant tu es chic et ben je m'adapte
qu'est-ce que ça je vous dirai plus tard
ce que je pense de vous
christina aguilera wekiss ennemi juré
c'est l'anglais alors elle c'est le
régime consiste à passer une semaine une
semaine en consommant seulement une
seule couleur d'aliments par jour jaune
rouge bleu noir vert je commence par
jean-michel époux fait de rire tu te
fous de christina aguilera va voir la
diffamation pour moi c'est pas bien
parce que c'est des artifices ça veut
dire que c'est c'est une façon de se
conditionner au travers d'un système
qu'on a inventé qui va être gris gris
dans la réalité je vais vous donner un
renseignement vous savez que dans
l'industrie agroalimentaire on utilise
de couleur l'orangé et le jaune ce sont
des couleurs qui augmente l'appétit et
al'inverse on sait que le bleu coupe
l'appétit non et donc quand tu prends
une couleur par jour s'est humblement tu
manges monotone une fois par jour et
donc tu te conditionne dans ta tête
final il reviendra jaune
orange et jaune et le bleu par exemple
quand vous regardez les boîtes de
bonbons des enfants fait un test on l'a
fait à l'east room et des bonbons on met
des bonbons aux enfants et les enfants
vont se précipiter vers l' orange et le
joint mais est il jette en général où
ils prennent le bleu basse qui reste
plus d'autres choses voilà mais le jeu
des couleurs c'est quelque chose qui
pauvres ils appellent une époque inventé
le régime rpt hausse on pouvait manger
tout ce qu'on veut route du champagne
brosse et dupont
et u17 des riches
au bout de huit jours les gens
mangeaient plus rien si on avait marqué
heures et puis ça crée des 40 j'imagine
à partir du moment où tu fais un régime
et où il ya des exclusions servir sinon
tu manges pas une alimentation
équilibrée ben oui tu vas manquer d'un
certain nombre de choses après tu
résistes tu tiens bien mais au bout d'un
moment ça c'est sentir absolument là
j'en suis souvent que le caviar le jour
c'est noir tu as que le caviar
[Rires]
truffes la date est allégué encore kbc
les gars
alors attention jennifer aniston ah oui
un peu pas non plus n'ont pas quoi
jennifer aniston
non mais vous confondez connu est belle
non le
nombre de personnes le nombre de
personnes vous les prenez vous les mecs
vous les mettez bouchard match il va
falloir trouver aucun charge vous les
mettez animateurs ils sont beaux à c'est
tout c'est un je te promets les belles
je t'aime un au rayon monoprix toi on
verra c'est à dire
alors c'est le baby food alors là je
sens que ça va bouffer à je les fais ça
oui le mot ce régime consiste à manger
tout au long de la journée dix à
quatorze petits pots pour bébé et
attendez avant de vous énerver chez un
médecin non jeûneurs deborah qui faisait
aussi le préfet un petit 30 kg + l'a
fait et les magnifiques en mai annoncée
bien comme ça qu'elle est guéri il veut
se fait poser un anneau gastrique et
semnon dans le petit pot ben oui à mende
au jeu l'ajax étape est rentré le petit
mais non
comprennent qu'un chewing contraint à
[Applaudissements]
l'abandon alors de plus qu'au manque
plus que même des couches pendant ce
régime quoi c'est
total oui bah ça nous arrivera tous
c'est une parabole l'abus lien c'est
alors moi je suis pas docteur mais je
vous expliquais une histoire qui m'est
arrivé comme vous pouvez constater à
nous y voilà
j'adore manger cher docteur alors aux
bois un jour on m'a dit tiens essai de
bataille au kilo j'ai donc essayé de
faire comme ces stars hollywoodiennes
alors une salade une soupe trois jours
plus tard la moitié des seins plus de
fès tout l'aspect musculaire qui tombait
mais oui mon visage creusé lessard a
placé vite j'ai commandé trois big match
j'étais au top de mon goût
l'explication
donnée les femmes convoi elles ont
toutes la même silhouette comme si
c'était fallait absolument avoir ce
corps sikhs banon y avoir des formes
c'est aussi très jolie les petits poser
dans l'explication c'est que parce
qu'après je serai sur mes bébés c'est
très bien équilibrée en générale mais un
petit peau de bébé il est censé faire
entre 90 et 120 calories quand tu en
manges disent tu as fait maximum 1200
calories donc tu es dans un régime
hypocalorique
après faut accepter de manger liquide
tout le temps avec des saveurs qui sont
assez moyennes et donc il faut avoir un
bénéfice à maigrir pour les quarts et
maintenant je savais même pas qu'il
existait d'ailleurs je ne savais pas
qu'on pouvait garder partir avec canton
quitté l'hôpital mardi en france est
interdit en france il s'appelle le
régime placenta donc en effet c'est
l'actrice de mad men qui a consommé elle
l'a gardé après avoir accouché elle a
consommé son propre placenta ces riches
en nutriments sous forme de pilules donc
le médecin lui a découpé pour chaque
jour une pilule placenta pour retrouver
les nuits après naissance de son fils
les scientifiques mettent en garde
contre cette pratique mais sachez qu'aux
états unis on peut se procurer quand
vous n'accrochez pas que vous n'êtes pas
une femme ddd placenta qui ont été en
gélules comme ça et consommer des
placentas chine car les humains vide
notamment alors là donc on n'a plus de
docteur n'a aucun sens sinon je suis
assez états unis on n'est pas loin du
cannibalisme yaris c'est absurde
ni bannissement on y va aller dans ce
cas nous faire les animaux
consommables ces consommables un tissu
quel qu'il soit qu'il soit d'une chaire
animale ou humaine ces consommables par
contre psychologiquement et
sociétalement parlant c'est un peu ça
genre de l'esat après ça tu manges ton
enfant
mais c'est extrêmement dangereux parce
qu'en 2016 est une maman qui acquit
allaiter son enfant qui avait fait ce
régime laïque qui a donné une infection
le ce qu'il faut comprendre pourquoi on
fait on fait ce plateau aujourd'hui qui
est extrêmement important parce que vous
savez tous les magazines vont sortir et
les magazines pour vendre on peut pas
leur en vouloir y mettre une star
américaine est derrière le régime et
nous héberge série si brad pitt est bon
on va faire comme lui et souvent c'est
très dangereux d'où la présence de deux
de deux médecins et quel médecin on est
très fiers d avoir alors celui là il m'a
intéressé c'est le régime à l'huile de
pamplemousse jennifer lopez quand même
qu'à 50 ans à 4 est belle elle renifle
de lui de pamplemousse chaque jour pour
garder la ligne pour quelles raisons les
effluves dégagée par le fruit semble
activer des enzymes du foie qui à son
tour accélère les nerfs qui décompose la
grèce ça c'est un régime religieux c'est
pour toi oui on s'épie rien eu mais
quelque chose quelque chose qui marche
c'est lourdes comment quand on va à
lourdes
ça peut arriver par ce biais là canonné
on tombe dans la magie déjà rien de déjà
à frédéric mais pamplemousse et
pamplemousse était dangereux non mais le
clan des mousses iliad huile à
l'intérieur déjà donc ça veut dire que
c'est une huile qui a été aromatisé au
pamplemousse et ça joue sur la
spéculation qu'on a eu pendant longtemps
pour la nasse ou pamplemousse comme quoi
ça brûler les graisses en fait il a
raison frédéric serre que normalement il
faut faire ce régime et faut l'associer
avec la prière qui va avec malgré le
trop divertissent yves dupont blum ou
sujet on va se faire une soirée
pamplemousse et gaza va y aller mais
j'entends de ces choses quand même qui
sont hallucinantes heureusement que vous
êtes là mais je veux dire quelque chose
c'est comme pour la muscu moi je connais
un petit peu la muscu et - les régimes
chaque année c'est comment te faire des
abdos en dix jours au bureau comment te
comment te commentaire je vais vous le
dire comment te c'est la patience de
l'indutrie sion du sommeil et laissez
passer le temps la percée des rares
médicaments terrestre et koné vous
muscler au bureau avec une agrafeuse
j'ai tout lu 1 la vérité c'est fait des
efforts et de la discipline
amanda seyfried
alors peut-être ça c'est intéressant le
régime cru les aliments crus sont ce qui
concerne le maximum de vitamines et
nutriments
sur lattes motif de ceux de son
alimentation pas pour apprendre je vais
y arriver à lire elle consiste à tout
mangé cru et donc à ne rien faire cuire
à plus de 47 degrés tout ce qu'elle
mange c'est cru faire dire que tu as
créé des détenus dans le monde des
cherifia coli listeria dans
les aliments là on vient d'en sortir
avec l'histoire des pizzas du tonnerre
on voit bien que les infections peuvent
être partout donc c'est effectivement il
y aura un peu plus de vitamines mais en
fait il ya beaucoup plus de risques on a
cuit les aliments justement pour éviter
les risques biologiques donc c'est archi
stupide et sans intérêt qui l'on peut
monter que la digestibilité s'adonne où
il continue à cuire à l'intérieur se
donnent des gaz et des preuves de
convivialité
c'est alors une dernière encore parce
que j'aurai beaucoup j'essaie d'aller au
plus hallucinant megan fox qu'on connaît
elle son truc c'est elle consomme 1 1
verre de vinaigre de pomme tous les
jours en grande quantité ça retient
l'eau ça augmente son métabolisme alors
en fait la réputation du vinaigre de
pomme ou du vinaigre de cidre ça a été
le fait qu'on avait considéré que ça
limiter l'absorption de certains
aliments dernier en fait ça à la limite
dans tellement peu de quantité avec
quand même un liquide extrêmement
irritant pour l'estomac ça n'a aucune
valeur mais tout ça ça sert à se
conditionner ça veut dire que c'est
comme si je m'étais un fétiche dans ma
main et je me dis tiens parce que j'ai
le fétiche je vais maigrir c'est son
appel de l'influencé d'un placebo
médecine d'alors la journée voilà vous
pouvez sur cette manne pour vous mettre
dans votre bouquin en touche et là vous
aimez madonna
alors attention ça s'appelle le régime
respirianisme une suite à la circulaire
abstention de nourriture les partisans
de cette méthode je précise qu'au fond
elle est comme ça sur un star les
partisans de cette méthode
que l'on peut se nourrir exclusivement
d'air et de lumière même l'on ne serait
pas nécessaire vous rendez compte que
cette femme-là ses fans pour entretenir
son corps la méthode repose sur une
dangereuse pratique du jeun totale du
jeune totale acquise à l'issue du
processus de 21 jours oco au cours
duquel le corps se libère
progressivement du besoin de manger et
de boire en gros elle dit que si tu
respires bien et que tu arrêtes de boire
et manger ton corps est bien fait comme
un animal et s'adapte bien sûr
franchement dangereux oui absolument
absurde oui le triomphe une importe quoi
et en plus craint que des gens suivent
bah oui on a on a fait des tests sur des
jeunes hydrique pendant 21 sur l'intérêt
jours c'étaient deux types qui
s'appelait blum et water loup dans les
années 60 est en fait au bout de 21
jours on avait une perte musculaire qui
était extrêmement impressionnante au
point que le foie été attaqué le coeur
et est attaqué car quand le corps n'a
plus de quoi manger que fait-il il
s'auto flagelle failli s'auto
cannibalise celle qui prend ce dont il a
besoin dans ces organes nobles c'est
dangereux stupide et en fait si vous
faites ça pendant 21 jours ont déjà au
bout de dix jours où j'ai les nerfs
question parce qu'il ne reste pas
beaucoup de temps est ce que quelqu'un
autour de ce plateau a fait un régime
qui a fonctionné pas toi ça un anneau
gastrique
moi j'ai fait un très grand jury qui
allait avec le sport l'art et perez
gaulle prononcé en fait c'est nabila qui
m'avait inspiré à dire vrai je suis très
sérieux en fait à partir de 18h
plus rien à cette hogra de costauds de
sucré mais par contre la journée je
mangeais ce que je voulais pour moi
j'essaie
c'est parce qu'en fait elles adorent et
picorer grignoter et c est en fait c'est
des fois plus facile de ne pas manger
que de manger un peu et c'est pour ça
qu'on faisait sa réaction après oui moi
quand j'avais 17 ans quand on conduit
les machins sont les peaux d'orange on
pressent très fort et on s'en trouve et
du coup ben moi je mangeais rien donc je
suis passé à 44 kg vous voyez le
cartilage au bout du nez ce que j'ai
chopé c'est un décollement de gencives
qui vaut témoignages
mais les actions américaines 30 secondes
les trois quarts se font vomir après les
repas quelles que soient les repas un
ancien régime attend juste je te jure qu
à toi moi j'ai fait j'ai fait du conflit
j'ai beaucoup maigri pont que j'ai fait
j'ai regardé à fresnes en revanche
double juste avant l'été ça m'a bien
aidé pour toi un peu la forme mais j'ai
repris après ludivine de nadjaf et 1 bah
oui et puis moi chez ti west que tout le
régime cétogène voilà exactement comme
ayem ce qui a à perdre mais je sais déjà
ce qu'elle jean-michel
ne l'appelle pas régime qui est au deuil
c'est un régime censure bien 5% glissade
serre 25 g de gras savoye voilà et donc
c'est on sait qu on maigrit vite mais je
n'aime pas non plus celui là et laurence
et je t'aime comme ça le rend un dernier
mot moi en régime fruits incident un
7/10 et d'orange tomates pendant trois
quatre jours orange et apple ou branches
fruits acides un régime fruits ainsi
naquit
vient ensuite voir ce régime c'est quoi
la beauté le talent champagne non
il faut faire le livre
là tu verras un jour tort à notre âge tu
ferais un régime prescrit par jean
michel cohen et le choeur sanaa